Okay. So, welcome everyone to lecture
number 10. We are towards the very last
part of the course.
So, let's just resume where we stopped
in the last lecture and do a very very
quick summary. So objective is always
the same for the last several lectures
that we are going to learn PTEES using
new networks
and we have sort of focused on learning
the PD solution operator from data using
operator learning so and we have various
different ways to do that right so we
have FNO CNO Scott whatn not and this
has been very very successful
particularly when you have PDS on 2D
cartesian domains we will change that
today and in the last lecture what we
had was an extension to time dependent
time dependent bes where we learn not
just the snapshots but the entire
trajectory of the solution and the key
sort of tool in that sense was to use
what is called all to all training but
there are still many caveats there's
still many limitations and this is where
we start off with or where we ended in
the last lecture which was that what we
did was intrinsically cartisian so your
input field uh and output field we're
both on cartigian grids but in reality
in engineering in particular this cannot
be right our world is not cartisian it's
only in video games that we have and
Lego that we can build everything out of
cartisian objects the world is
intrinsically non-cartisian uh as you
can see this is an example this is a
mesh or input points for and output
points for flow past an air foil uh
supersonic flow past an air foil I think
this is mark 3 so So you can see that
the point cloud is all over the place.
It's far from cartesian because
cartesian would be equally spaced
points. Something like this, right?
Whereas you can see very clearly how
non- cartesian the whole setup is. There
are points everywhere and these
structures that you see are actually
points. Right? Because the solution it's
an adaptive mesh. So you have uh
information which is very very localized
and this is already in 2D and in 3D of
course uh without saying this becomes
even more complicated. This is a mesh an
actual mesh on the surface of a formula
1 car and you can see that there is a
lot of anisotropy and there are a lot of
points everywhere in the tires on the
underside and so on. So this shows that
or this tells us that to do real world
problems we cannot be in stuck in this
cartesian regime we have to do something
which is beyond cartitionian. So in
principle we have to extend our neural
operators or the learning frameworks
that we've learned to work with
unstructured grids and as general as
point clouds right so you'll be given a
cloud of points your inputs will be
there your outputs will be sort on this
count cloud of points and the objective
would be to learn the PD solution
operator on that so how do we do that so
this will be my main objective today and
hopefully we will have good answers at
the end of uh today's lecture so is the
setting clear. Okay, very good. So I
think uh I just briefly touched on it
that there are different ways to do it
but the way that we are going to start
off today is what are called graph
neural networks and graph neural
networks are going to be useful anyway
later on in the course. So let's start
with that. So what is a graph neural
network? As you can imagine or
understand from the name itself, this is
learning data that is sitting on graphs
instead of cartigian or ukidian domains.
it is sitting on graphs. So this is how
it looks like. This is a graph of a
social network. As you can a part of
Facebook perhaps uh as you can imagine
there are these hubs and spokes which
are typical of social network data. So
as I said input data on graphs is
ubiquitous. So you can imagine social
networks Facebook uh Twitter, LinkedIn
whatever where uh the node of the graph
is each of us and the links or the edges
are if we have a connection to each
other or not. Right? Then on transport
systems the public transport system of
Jurich you can go and check any of the
sort of transport maps and you can see
that there is a graph is given there
recommener systems. So if you want uh to
use YouTube, they're constantly
bombarding you with uh ads which are
tailored towards you and this is based
on recommended systems which in
particular sitting on graphs. But this
is from sort of the social sciences uh
and economics and so on from chemistry
and biology molecules. So what are
molecules after all? Molecules are you
have atoms which are bonded together by
different bonds and they form molecules.
So graphs are very very important there.
The entire data is represented as graphs
and in fact David in the last couple of
lectures of the course actually in two
weeks a little more than two weeks he
will be talking about chemistry and
biology and there the role of graphs is
very very important and finally as you
can imagine the simulations that I
showed you the meshbased simulations
that we do if you look at it these are
essentially graphs so these are nodes
and these are edges on the graph so in
principle the data that we have in
principle is on graphs right so even in
meshbased simulations we have graphs
there so graphs are data on graphs is
going to be very very important so the
question is how do we represent this
data and how do we learn this data I
know that you have had a tutorial
earlier in the week where at least some
of these concepts are covered and this
will again be covered when David is
going to talk about them so I'll be
rather brief and concise in what I'm
saying So most of you should know as
students of science and engineering you
should know what graphs are. So graphs
with this additional complexity not
complexity but feature that data is
sitting on them are represented in terms
of three essential objects. So first are
the nodes or uh well let's call them the
nodes and this is as I said the most
important objects. So this is for
instance this could be us in a social
network uh members of society that's the
nodes then we have the edges the
connections between the nodes right not
everything is connected to everything
else so points are connected or nodes
are connected to each other and what
connects us for instance a link um if I
and you are friends then we have a link
between us these are either links or
edges so this is of course another
feature of a graph and the final feature
of a graph of course is uh the fact that
we also have data right so on each of
this is for instance in a social network
this could just be my age or your age so
this data can sit on the nodes it can
also sit on the links for instance in a
transport network you can think of nodes
being different I don't know transport
hubs but uh and the links being the
roads that connect them or the tram
lines that connect them and the edge
feature for instance could be the time
amount of time it takes to go from one
link to the other right so you can have
data sitting on nodes, you can have data
sitting on edges and you can have some
global context data. So these three
things the nodes, the edges and the data
they define uh the structure or the
composition of a graph right and the
final object which I think many of you
are familiar with is the so-called
adjacency matrix. So this is you just
put the nodes on one side, you put all
the nodes on another side and you put a
one if there is a link between the two
nodes. For instance, this guy here and
this guy here have a link. So it's a
one. And if there is no link between
them, for instance, these two, then you
put a zero. So the entire structure of a
graph, the structure of its edges can be
represented in terms of this one zero
matrix, this binary matrix which is
called adjacency matrix. This goes to
play a role. And I think all of us
should be familiar with this very very
basic facts about graphs. Right? Now you
have this uh load of information. you
have data on a graph uh and then what do
we do with it? For instance, for a
meshbased simulations, we can imagine
that the nodes are coordinates, points,
right? Uh just we'll see examples later.
But let's take a concrete example. This
is flow past an air foil. So each of
these links, each of the nodes is of
course a point on the outer surface, not
on the surface but outer volume of the
air foil. So that's your node. Link is
the edge is if these points are
neighbors of each other or not, right?
one neighbors of each other or not. And
the data for instance could be
temperature, pressure, whatever. And on
the on the node itself, it's
temperature, pressure, and so on. And on
the edges, it could be their gradients,
right? Because gradients are after all
based on your neighbors. So this is the
structure that we are going to deal
with.
So in order to process this data instead
of you can't just use a standard neural
network. You can use an MLP in any case,
but for instance, you can't use a
convolutional neural network
or a recurrent neural network or a
transformer just like that. You have to
process them by some special means. And
these special means are called
graph neural networks and they have been
around now for quite a while at least 20
25 years and they're a very very popular
way of using neural networks in the
connection in connection to this kind of
graph based or relational data. So again
as I said uh the graph uh you can
localize it. A graph after all is a
local object. Uh it's intrinsically
local even if the links are far away
they are local to the particular node.
So what I'm taking is a piece of the
graph. So you can imagine so these are
my my nodes here. These are the links
and then there are some global features.
So U is sitting on the node. V is
sitting on the link. So these are
features that are there. E is sitting
globally. And then you take some this is
just a highle picture of it right then
you take some neural networks
essentially and you're going to update
the values on the nodes and on the links
or edges as well as global features
right and you do it as all neural
networks are based on composition. So on
each layer you update the no node
features the edge features and the
global features and you have layers
stacked on top of each other. So you
keep on updating it. Right? So this is
roughly the idea of a graph neural
network. It's very similar to what we do
for um standard neural networks, right?
When you have been given an input
vector, we push it through MLP and then
we update it. It's it's very similar to
that except that you have to take care
of the fact that the graph has its any
node on a graph has its neighbors, the
ones that are connected to it using
edges. So let me just write down what it
is and the basis of all graph neural
networks is a concept which is called
message passing. So let me try to
explain what message passing is. So this
is sort of the key key ingredient in
graph neuronet networks. So what is what
is message passing? So what happens uh
graphically
pun intended is the following. So
remember that I want to I'm interested
in updating let's for simplicity look
only at node features for the time
being. Same principle applies to edge
and global features. So I'm interested
in updating the node features at this
particular point in the in the graph. So
what do I do? I take information from
all the neighboring points. So for this
particular graph, you can see that this
is a neighboring point. This is a
neighboring point and the point itself
is its own neighbor. Its features do
matter. So what I'm going to do is I
take the information from this point. I
take its own information. I a process
them and aggregate them in some manner
and then I process them again to get an
update. Okay. So this is a very very
simple idea that if you're sitting on a
graph you take information from all your
neighbors so all the points which are
connected by edges uh and then you take
those features put them through MLP
aggregate the information and then
process it right so this is what is done
here I'll give you many examples so as
you can imagine so vi is the node at
which we are going to update and the
update is hi right so what do I do here
I take information from all its
neighbors. VJ are all the neighbors,
right? N I is neighbors of I. I take
this information, process it. So each of
these pairs, I'm going to process it
typically by an MLP, but this will have
some specific structure which we will
see in the next slide. Then I'll
aggregate this information by some
aggregation function. Aggregation is
usually a sum, right? Sum is the
standard aggregation, but it could also
be a product. It could be could be
something else an average whatever a
maximum perhaps or a minimum I get this
aggregation then I send everything
through an MLP again so that's it so I
have essentially a couple of MLPS I pull
feature for and I do it for every single
node in the graph right so at each layer
what do I do I sit at each point I get
all the neighbors pull them together get
the information put it through MLPS
update my value and I keep on doing it
at every single point. So lot of
messages are being exchanged and then
over each layer as I have 100 layers or
50 layers I keep on exchanging this
messages. So in principle it is very
very simple structure right and if your
graph is very sparse these are very few
messages for each uh node if your graph
is very dense there are lots of messages
for every node right so this is uh you
you have no control a priority unless
until you see the structure of the graph
and I'll give you some examples in a in
a bit just to make it more concrete make
these ideas more concrete but in the
meanwhile if you have any questions
about this very very basic structure I'm
happy to answer them yes go ahead uh can
one include edge weights in
>> yes absolutely you can do edge and
global features I just tried to be as
simple as possible and that's why I said
okay let's just focus on node features
nothing else is given but in principle
here you could have edge eig also and
some global features also some context
information and in practice this is
always used but I just made it very
simple here further questions no okay
let's see some examples and then See
what is the what what we can do in this
context. Right? Good. So the classic
example this is many many 10 12 years
old is called what is called a graph
convolution neural network. Graph
convolution network or a GCN. These are
essentially the analogs of convolutional
neural networks and they are very very
simple to some extent I would say. So
what happens uh in a graph uh
convolution uh network remember that in
principle I have to specify the
structure of this MLP what is the form
of this aggregation function and the
structure of this MLP then I can define
what a what a graph neural network is so
in this particular case it's extremely
simple so what you do is you sit at this
point you get information from the
neighbors okay you get information from
the neighbors which is given by this and
you only push that uh neighboring node
feature through a matrix essentially. So
you are this matrix is the same across
all the nodes. So that's why it is
convolution right because the
convolutional kernel is not being
changed. So this is just mixing the
channel features. It's called channel
mixing. You're not really getting you're
not really involving mutual or pair-wise
interactions here. It is just channel
mixing here and then you're sort of
normalizing it using so this A is the
adjacency matrix
adjacy matrix
and this D's are what are called degrees
or extended degrees. If it is without
the one it would be the degree but this
is extended degree. So you normalize it
and once you normalize it so this is the
this is a very very simple operation
nothing nonlinear just linear you are
just mixing the channel weights at each
point and then you are aggregating
everything by just a sum so nothing
fancy is happening and finally you send
it through an MLP actually if you're
sitting on a mesh you know if you're
sitting on a mesh and you use a linear
convolution kernel then you can easily
show that this is indeed a convolution
this is straightforward forward
exercise. So in other words, if you're
sitting on a mesh something like this,
right? And you want to aggregate
information, you'll see that this
corresponds to a convolution or a
particular form of convolution. So this
is a very very simple effective starting
uh neuronet network graph neuronet
network that one can use. Nothing is
fancy here. The nonlinearity comes in
through the activation function G
essentially and everything else is
linear. This is just mixing the
channels. very sparse, very easy to code
and very very easy to compute, right?
Because it's very very fast. But it's
not as you can imagine that there is
only so much of expressivity that this
kind of a neural network uh can have
because all that you're doing is you're
getting information from each of the
points mixing them putting them into
some embedded space or this is what this
W does adding them and then passing them
through an activation. It's as simple as
that. So perhaps it's not as expressive.
clear this structure very easy to
implement an improved version so this is
uh due to k and welling if I'm at least
they were
maxwelling and thomas k were the first
people to probably write it in this
format it's very very simple uh so gat
is a I would say more expressive and
widely used uh network this is based on
attention you'll see in a second and
this is from petarovich's
a PhD thesis. So this is maybe 2017 this
is maybe or 2016 this is 2020 around the
2018 around the same time that uh
attention that we have already covered
was uh was around right so the idea is
again very very simple so remember that
all the time I have to define how do I
aggregate the how do I pull information
from my neighbors how do I aggregate it
and what I pass it through that's all
right so in this case what par and his
collaborators argued is that uh so here
is a specific example. So what you do is
again you do this channel mixing. Okay.
So you take the features you put them in
an embedded space but now instead of
weighing the relationship based just on
the degree based on the local
connectivity you make it a little bit
smarter and make it data dependent by
essentially using what we it's a soft
max based weight. I don't I didn't write
down the details here. we know exactly
how to do this kind of softmax based
waiting in uh in the context of
transformers in the context of attention
and it does that. So it weighs how much
of relative information this VJ
contributes to VI right. So this plays a
little bit of a role the role of VI. So
you take this pair wise information and
you aggregate it and then you sum it
over this is again a sum you pass it
through an MLP. So what is the
difference between the two? So earlier
this uh attention weights this quadriure
weights you can think of these were
given by some fixed numbers not learned
now they are learned right so this is
sort of the difference between the two
but this very very simple change makes
it uh so it's some sort of some form of
a local weak attention and it makes it
very very sort of expressive much more
expressive so this is the one that is
often used as there are much more um
let's say elaborate architectures
including from my lab but uh this is
there are there are too many graph
neuronet networks. So these are the two
basic ones that are widely used. So you
see the difference right? So here the
relationship between the between the
points is given in terms of a fixed
quantity the extended degree and here it
is learned through an attention weight
that's all otherwise it's very very
simple very very simple changes but I
think this very simple change has some
implications when it comes to
expressivity and so on so now the
question is so this was a very sort of a
easy introduction to graph neural
networks I didn't really dwell much one
can spend the entire lecture talking
about graph neural networks. I didn't
want to do it because uh you already had
a tutorial. We have a lot of other
material to cover and also we are going
to see this in the context of chemistry
and biology. So you'll have some
exposure to graph neuronet networks. The
question is with these very simple
basics how do we work with operator
learning right? So and again there are
many many different uh ideas but let me
just highlight the one that comes out of
my lab so that uh there is a concrete
concrete thing that we can latch on to
and this is uh more recent work it's
called rigno uh let me try to expand it
and this is called um region invariant
graph neural operator but essentially
it's it uses MPNN
so in principle it does not use these
sort of specific ansats the specific
structures uh graph convolutions or
graph attention it relies on the full
MLP. So all these MLPS are trained
right. So this is it does not does not
assume any specific structure but the
main differences between this and what
you have seen so far is that this is
sort of heavily sort of engineered. It
has a lot of inductive biases. It has
been heavily engineered to do the sort
of stuff that we are interested in. So
let me just try to explain it at a high
level. I mean the details are not that
important here. You'll see that uh what
the results are. So what is our
objective? Our objective is that we have
been given some inputs. Let's try to
hyperloize it. So what are the inputs?
So this is PD operator learning. So you
have the coordinates, right? So after
all there is some input graph. I don't
know how well you see it but this is not
a cartian grid by any means. Okay. These
are some random point clouds. So this
this is able to deal with random point
clouds. And then you have some features.
This could be an initial condition for
instance in this particular case. And
then you have some this is the wave
equation. If you remember this is a wave
equation. So you have some initial data.
So earthquakes at different points. You
have some coefficients. This is given by
this layered information the wave
speeds. And then the output is given by
the solution at a later time. So we are
given the current time as an input also
time dependent PDEs we are given the
lead time as an output uh as an input.
So given u at t you want to update u at
t + so that's the idea right. So this is
a very concrete objective and this
information is given. So the interesting
thing here is that what we do is that we
put the this coordinate information onto
a graph. So you can see that this is
your input graph but to do so we use
some embeddings right so so the name of
the game is always to use some
embeddings and these embeddings are
given by feed forward networks MLPS
right so this is this is how the
embedding looks like so you can see that
it goes through an MLP some
normalization some residual connections
and then you have features on a graph
and this is your input graph or your
input point cloud right but uh on
sitting on it each of the features
is in this embedded space. Machine
learning is all about this smart
embeddings, this coordinate
transformations and this is what you do
here. Now the graph is not built at the
level of this uh original input mesh
because that would be very very
expensive to operate on even in 2D. This
mesh is like 10,000 to 50,000 points or
100,000 points. It's quite quite rich.
We are not going to do that. Instead
what we do is that we build a graph
between this what is called a input mesh
maybe I write it down
this oh gosh it's too big
let's do so this is your input mesh
input grid
or input point cloud it could be and
latent
So this is where all the relational
structure is being learned. So as you
can see and this way we were going to
repeat this process. So we take any
point in the latent grid and we sort of
connected by a graph to points in the
input grid. So information here is done
through message passing through a graph.
So it's not like these neighbors are
passing information to each other out
here. they will pass information to each
other out down here at this latent grid
which is a coarser version of the
original grid but uh they pass
information using message passing. Okay.
And then once you have this information
then within this there are many many
layers where each of these guys are
going to pass messages using general MLP
general message passing there's no
specific structure no convolutions no
GAT nothing so just very very general
make it as general as possible and
knowing uh remember with CNO with Scott
we do it in a hierarchical manner right
because we start with a fine mesh this
is supposed to represent the fine
features coarseness cosen it further
coin it further. So in each block we do
or not in each block but across the
blocks we do this kind of uh message
passing through this hierarchical mesh
construction and then after many many
layers we have some features that are on
this latent grid and we want to go back
to the input grid. Right? So what we do
is again at any point on the input grid
we connect to points on the latent grid
by a graph essentially by using
neighbors. Right? uh by using graphs do
some message passing and then once you
have it there you want to get back into
the coordinates and you do it through
that and as you can see we use edges we
use uh all kinds of features global
features edges and nodes in order to do
this. So what stands out? So we need uh
we we essentially need this hierarchical
information hierarchical
multiscale perhaps that's the better
word to use here. We have done that many
many times but we do this here for
graphs. So multiscale message passing
and this hierarchical graph
construction. Okay. So this is without
this you cannot do physics because
physics is inherently a multiscale or
there are many many multiscale processes
here and again I didn't want to go into
the details because we we have to make
some choices right and then there are
many many modifications over the
literature to first of all okay I didn't
even see that I have multiscale
information processing you saw the you
saw the architectural changes there and
then we do many things to ensure
temporal continuity and also the
resolution invariance because this is
after all a very very important point
here. It's not exactly resolution
invariant but we can make it
approximately resolution invariant and
in the paper we have some some examples.
Now I don't expect you in this very very
short um exposure five six minute
description to understand all the
details of this particular construction
but the idea is that you can combine
graph new yes
>> you can actually see the native graph
determin
>> yeah so this is based on a fairly
complicated algorithm which takes into
account not just roughly speaking there
are more more more pieces to what I'm
saying roughly speaking nearest
neighbors and some random distant
connections.
Okay, so you it looks like we are just
connecting nearest neighbors but that is
not always the case. We also have some
long-distance connections which we do
essentially randomly so that we can have
global information transfer or we can
aid global information transfer because
in principle remember that on this
particular graph you are passing several
messages right so in the first layer you
are getting information from the one
neighbors these are the neighbors that
are directly connected to it in the
second one you're getting information
from two neighbors in the third one from
three neighbors in the fourth one from
four neighbors and because we are doing
it in a hierarchical manner Eventually
our smallest graph here is you are
having global information exchange right
because there are just two few points
there. So of course they are all talking
to each other in some sense. However to
aid this information transfer we also
have some random uh features. So but the
key key reason why we have global
information is because we have this
hierarchical construction. Okay that's a
very good question. Further questions?
No. And I don't know if he covered this
in the tutorial, but this is a more
sophisticated. It's graph neural
networks on steroids. Right? So this is
the basic idea that you cannot just use
a graph convolutional neuronet network
and expect good results in this domain
because this is not having the
expressivity, the power to approximate
very complex features. So the building
blocks are exactly what we have seen
before simple message passing. But how
we put it together requires some
innovation, some domain knowledge and
this is what is being used here. Okay.
So let me try to show you some results.
What are the advantages? What are the
disadvantages of this kind of an of an
approach? So the main advantage of
course is that uh this extremely
flexible in some sense. You'll see see
examples of that.
So here is a good example. So as you can
see uh this is the sheer layer or
sinusol vortex sheet as it is called. So
your input is just the initial
conditions right. This is Navia Stokes.
NS is always Navia Stokes. In 2D, all
the examples that I'll show you in 2D
because you'll see what what is the
issue in 3D in a in a bit. So the
initial conditions as you can notice
they are not given on a cartigian grid.
They could be given on a cartigian grid.
We generated it on a cartigian grid. But
just to make things very general, this
is given essentially on a random point
cloud. You can see just visually that
this is a random point cloud. So this is
the initial velocity in one direction,
the initial velocity in the other
direction. The ground truth uh things
happen. Vortices are formed. Uh you can
see that in the x direction you have
shear along this direction. In the y you
have the shear along the other
direction. So fairly complicated
solution. Rigno the model that I just
showed you it does a very very good job
means it's able to handle it quite well.
And there is error of course there is
error but the error is relatively small.
In fact, in this particular case, it's
even less than 1%. It's 0.5%.
Uh, some of the other approaches are
very GO, we'll see that later after the
break that go is also quite okay. It's
about 1.2%. So, it can handle things on
very random point clouds, although this
is actually a cartian problem in some
sense. Right now, the next one is a
proper unstructured problem. It's a flow
past an air foil. Again, uh, does a very
very good job. You can see that the
input is this adaptive mesh and the
output is going to have this shock wave
and so on. It's not the hardest problem.
You'll see harder problems uh in a bit.
And again, it does a very very good job.
It has about 1% error compared to the
baselines. It's twice as accurate. This
is plasticity. Another example where uh
the shape changes, right? You're putting
deformations, plastic deformations, and
things get deformed. So this is your
original mesh. You put some loading. So
things get deformed and again it does a
very very good job compared to other
baselines. Geno also does well but so
essentially you have the intrinsic
flexibility of being able to handle
arbitrary domains. Arbitrary domain
geometries is the last example that I
wanted to show you. This is waves on a
circle means uh so the input is given
here on a circle. So you can't put a
cartigian grid then you don't get the
geometric information correct. Then
these waves move around. As you can see
this feature here is moved around
somewhere here. Again does a good job.
The error is about 5%. But the other
approaches are also relatively well
here. So actually this is a very very
accurate method means um not
surprisingly perhaps because a lot of
thought has been gone into its
construction. So all across um different
domains it does a very very good job
means these are unstructured data sets.
For instance, wave equation, this is
about is the hardest one. I would say
it's about 6%. Also, this compressible
oiler, it's about 7%, so these these are
hard data sets. But its nearest
competitor here is about 25%. So, you
can imagine that this this does very
very well. And even on uniform grids,
because there is nothing specific since
it can handle any point cloud in
particular, it can handle uniform grids,
right? So even on uniform grids it is
surprisingly better in some problems
than for instance CNO. Some problems it
is not better but in some some other
problems it's much better. Let's take an
example perhaps this one. Let's look at
this one. Look. So this is 1.12%.
So CNO for instance is 2%. Scott is
2.5%. FNO is 2%. So because of this
hierarchical construction and the
intrinsic locality of the problem, it
seems that the graph neural network
actually does better on some of these
problem. Not on all of them. This one I
think it did very very well compared to
CNO and FNO not so well compared to
Scott. But so it has the intrinsic
flexibility and it has the accuracy. And
this is what what you really want in a
method, right? You want your method to
be very very accurate and flexible. But
what is the issue then? then why didn't
I show you some good examples in 3D? So
the problem is that there's always some
caveats. So graph neural networks are
very good and in fact deep mind they
have used graph neural networks even to
predict the weather because earth is a
spear. So you can you can build a graph
neural network on that and their neural
network is not very different from ours.
There are there are some small
differences but it's more or less the
same. But the problem is that it's not
efficient and I will explain this chart
in a in a bit. So for instance some of
these problems uh maybe this one for
instance it's a cartician grid 2D but a
lot of points like 10,000 to 50,000
points so it took more than 2 days of
training for such a cartian problem if
it takes 2 days of training it is too
long and if you look at this radar chart
uh so what is this radar chart so it has
different axes so on this side you have
and you'll see this again this is your
accuracy
and on this side is efficiency
So accuracy it's for instance uh what am
I saying accuracy for the time
independent accuracy for the time
dependent problems some robustness
metrics means how robust are the results
and so on so this is more on the
accuracy front this is on the on the
efficiency efficiency is usually
measured and how it scales with respect
to model size how it scales with respect
to input size how the what is the
training throughput what is the
inference speed inference latency and so
And you can see that rigno is uh in this
transparent blue. So it is an accurate
model. It's very accurate here, accurate
here, perhaps not so accurate here, but
maybe the most accurate. Uh and here
it's also the most robust, but it's not
very efficient. Means other models are
more efficient than it. And this is the
main reason. So there's an engineering
reason. And the reason is that you are
constantly doing sparse memory access,
right? It's a graph after all. So the
data structure is intrinsically sparse.
So at each time of the loop you get
information which is so you have to the
the memory compute equation right the
memory access compute so you want to
access as little from memory as possible
and do as much compute as possible so
that the arithmetic intensity is going
to be large but here with graphs they
can be if you put an asex which does it
exactly this can be done but on modern
GPUs that is not the case. So it takes
it's hard to train it particularly in
the graph changes. If the graph is fixed
you can sort of um make things into disk
and so on and engineer it to do quite
well. This is what the deep mind people
did for instance for weather prediction.
But in general if you are looking at and
you'll see some numbers after the break
if you're looking at anything like a
million nodes this becomes almost
intractable. It just doesn't scale on
modern GPUs. So accurate but not
efficient. So what we need is a method
that has not just accuracy but
efficiency and this is what I am going
to do after the break. You can see that
there is such a method right which is
able to provide both but we we will
learn about that after the break. So
let's take a quick 10-minut break. Uh we
meet here at 10. Okay.
So let's pause the
welcome back everyone. So the issue is
we want to combine accuracy and
efficiency right. So combine accuracy
and efficiency.
This is not an issue on cartian grids
because uh convolutions or attention
there is very very efficient anyway. So
particularly after using vision or spin
transformers. So what do we do means
there are many many choices and many
different ways to do this. Let me give
you what I believe is a good solution
because I know it the best. It's from my
lab and it does very well. So let's
let's start with that. So the solution
is actually a combination between graphs
and transformers. And let me try to
explain this. It's called geometry aware
operator transformer. It's a very recent
paper. It's uh the short form is goat
even though it spells like gay but it's
really goat. So
just quote right okay so what is the
idea of uh behind this right and I'll
explain the details quite a bit so how
do we combine graphs and transformers in
a in a way to improve uh keep accuracy
because remember that graphs are already
quite accurate so the key is how do we
make them more efficient right so I I
will cover all the things uh in some
detail in the next slides but let me
give you the highle picture so the idea
behind it is that it uses is what is and
in the next lecture in the next slide it
is uh used heavily. It uses what is
called a encode process decode paradigm.
Now this is a paradigm that is very
common in machine learning. It was also
used here in uh rigno for instance
right. So where we said that the
encoding is through this embedding and
you go all the way here you en encode
information in a latent grid you do all
this multiscale information processing
in latence grid and then you come back.
So this is a similar spirit except that
in um rigno in graph new networks the
encoding and the decoding the processing
was done on a graph. Here the processing
is done on a different kind of a latent
grid. Right? So the idea is that you
have information and you have to pay
some attention because the figures here
are small but I'll explain each of this
uh later on. So the blue points is your
input input point cloud right? So this
uh flow across an air foil. So you can
imagine that it is a lot of points near
the tip a lot of points along the shock
waves and very little points over here.
So this information the blue points is
conveyed onto a latent grid. A latent
grid is just like in the previous case
it was a graph. Here it will be a
structured grid or a cartian grid and
the latent grid is sitting somewhere
here. So it's just a cartian grid. So
you have to get information from the
blue points which is your input grid
right or your input point cloud into the
cart into the latent grid which is the
red points. I don't know how well you
see the red points. So you have
information transfer that goes from a
complex domain to a simpler domain.
Right? So this is in some sense inspired
what we do in PDEs or in physics in
general that you have information on
something complex. We transform it into
something more tractable something more
simple. And in this particular case it
is going to be a cartian grid right. So
we will get information. We have some
information coordinates. We have the
physical field some sign distance
functions and we have ways to move
information from this very complex point
cloud to something much more tractable
and this is what is done by its encoder.
So remember that there's an encoder and
I'll describe the details uh in a in a
sec in the next slide. So information on
this very complex point cloud is
transformed into latent information on a
latent point cloud or latent grid which
is much simpler to handle once this
information is there. So this
information we call it as tokens because
this will be used for a uh for a
transformer. So these are what I call
geometry aware tokens. I'll define them
and once they are on a transformer
they're once they're on a cartisionian
grid you can patch them for instance. So
these are patch tokens and then you can
throw them into a transformer through
embeddings, normalizations and so on and
so forth and you have multiple
transformer blocks with lots of residual
connections in between and at the end of
the day you get some latent features. So
this is the latent processed feature and
then what you do is uh you have to
decode the information right you have to
go back to your original grid or in this
case you have to go back to any
particular point that you wish. So in
particular you want to go back to the
blue points from the red points and you
do this process which was in this
direction completely in the reverse. So
this is the decoder here and then you
get the information here. So the higher
level is that you take information which
is on a very complex domain. You map it
in a machine learning manner learn
manner into something on a much simpler
domain. You use your favorite uh
cartisian type processor, FNO, CNO,
transformer. We use transformers because
of some obvious advantages. You'll see
that in a bit. And then we go through
the loop and come back through the
decoder. Okay. So this is the basic
idea. It's not a very surprising idea
per se, but it's the details that
matter. And this is how the efficiency,
the accuracy of this has been built
through that. Right? So let me try to
explain what the encoder is, what the
processor is and what the decoder is.
But at this level, are there any
questions about this general idea? It's
a very appealing idea, right? You take
information which is on something
complex and you map it onto something
which is simpler and then process it.
Nothing nothing fancy about that. Okay.
So let us start about uh the the
architecture itself. So as I said it's
based on encode process decode strategy.
Almost everything is based on that
strategy or can be put into that
framework. That's not very surprising.
And the main role of the encoder as I
just explained is to go from this very
complex point cloud onto something which
is simple what we call as a latent grid
need not be a grid but let's for
simplicity call it as a latent grid. And
there are different choices that can be
made right. So there are what are the
different choices? So just locally so
the blue is your input points which are
essentially random. This is a point
cloud. So one strategy the one that I
showed you in the picture in the sort of
schematic before was uh a cartian grid
right so you have this point clouds and
you map them onto a cartian grid so of
course in some cases you have many
points which fall into that in some
other cases you have no points which
fall into that there's a void and so on
this is inevitable that's one strategy
it has its big advantages another
strategy is what we did in the graph
which is to subsample the input point
cloud So here you because you need some
information distillation some
information disagregation. So what you
do is that you pick some of these points
arguably randomly as your um as your
latent points right that's also a
strategy. The third strategy which is a
bit harder to understand is particularly
in 3D it's based on some planer what are
called trip plane embeddings but uh this
is this is a possibility I will not
really discuss that. So I'll mostly
focus on these two guys. uh what are the
comparative advantages and disadvantages
but the latent grid in principle has to
be simpler to deal with than your
original input right so this is the
basic idea so how do we move information
once we make a choice of this this is
userdefined once we make a choice there
are some ablations in the paper which
say which is superior and which is not
how do we sort of move information
between the latent grid between the
input grid and the latent grid and how
do we move information back right the
information is moved by using an
encoder. So this let me explain what
this encoder is all about. It is in some
sense very similar to a graph neural
network but it doesn't use message
passing to that extent. Let me explain
what it is.
So let us take a simple example here or
maybe I want to see which one maybe this
one is even easier.
So let us say that I want to get
information at this point right because
what after all is my encoder doing it is
providing me information at all the red
points right so I want to get
information at the red points so let me
pick one of them let us say which one
did I pick let's say that I pick this
point uh I want to get information so
what I do is I look in its neighbor
neighborhood we always have geometric
information I look at its neighborhood
and I accumulate information so it's
similar ilar to what we did in graph
neural networks. We looked at the
neighbors, we built the graph and we got
information from the neighbors. But now
instead of having general message
passing, we essentially use a kernel
here. So what do we do? We look at all
the points. Uh so we have been given
some input field A. So this is my input,
right? And from the input I wanted to go
to a
embed and a latent feature vector or
latent feature field we at any latent
point Y. So what do I do? I search for
all the input points that are within
some R neighborhood. R is some
userdefined hyperparameter and then I
accumulate information from these
points. For instance, I can take the
input field, pass it through an MLP and
then use a kernel here. So the kernel,
so this if you think of it, it is
nothing but x - y v of a of y dy d or
the other way around. Sorry, let me let
me write it carefully.
So what is this kernel approximating?
This kernel is approximating
let me use orange.
So some local neighborhood of k of x
this could also be a function of a y x -
y
and then we have f of x
p of a of x.
I should have written it down
and then dx something like this. Right?
So it's essentially approximating a
kernel. You pass it through this and
then you have a learnable kernel that we
are going to learn a linear kernel and
of course when we approximate it we get
some quadature weights right so this is
the basic uh architecture here you get
uh information through this MLP and you
aggregate it through this kernel
function okay this is this is the basic
idea and you do it locally there is
nothing nothing distill about the whole
approach so what we suggested uh shien
who is one of your tutors it's his uh
work in some sense what he suggested is
that instead of choosing these weights
um sort of fixed manner why don't we
choose it by attention so this is
similar to what people do in GAT for
instance right that the kernel weights
are chosen by using attention so it's a
bit along the same lines so what you do
is that instead so the relative
importance is what is uh mattering here
so you take uh your point you multiply
it with the query mat matrix you take uh
your other input point you multiply ly
with a key matrix you normalize it and
then you put a soft max so this I don't
know why NY should be here right so this
was a mistake here okay so this is just
a standard attention weight so it's
called attention and since there is a
graph neural operator here it's called
attentional graph neural operator okay
so information is just collected it's a
light layer that gives information from
the lat from the input grid into the
latent grid but our main sort of
advantage or before literature. So this
was introduced in this particular paper
to use attention. It's simply going from
a sort of a convolutional approach to a
attention based like GAT did right but
our main sort of innovation I would say
is this multiscale aggregation so what
we do in this is that instead of just
looking at one set of points remember
that the name of the game is multiscale
information processing. So what we do is
that uh so we are sitting at this red
point. So earlier we would just look at
its nearest neighbors right and say okay
we are just content with information for
the nearest neighbors but then we said
no no let's not do that let's look at uh
further neighbors let's look at even
further neighbors and so on and try to
get information out of them and
accumulate them properly so this was the
idea so you have some multiscale
information processing and the formula
is written here so you have uh m scales
capital m scales okay or nmmy y scales
and you have different red eye of a radi
of aggregation, right? So you do this
for each of this you have a different
MLP and you learn different
contributions. So it says that maybe
local information is more weighted than
more distant information. This is the
idea, right? Or maybe more distant
information is more weighted. It'll it
depends on the learning process to learn
that. So you try to make it as much
multiscale as possible just like we did
with the graph neuronet networks, right?
So this is the encoder. But what about
geometric information? Because here the
geometric information is not yet
conveyed because all that you are
getting is local coordinate information.
You know what is y and what is xk
nothing else. So we need to convey some
geometric information which is a more
global quantity in some sense. Of course
we have the point coordinates. These are
anyway given to us. We can use sign
distance functions. Uh distance
functions are a way or sign distance
functions are a way to represent global
geometry. For instance we can use the
sign distance function corresponding to
air foil. So it for instance tells this
point how far is it from the boundary
which in this case is the boundary of
the air foil right because that
determines how the flow looks like for
instance. But what is our innovation
this is standard is to use some local
embeddings some statistical embeddings
to give more rich geometric information.
So you compute what are the number of
neighbors
for a given point you compute its
average distance its variance some local
anisotropies. So these are details
important details but these are just
details. So you have some geometric
embeddings. So you have information uh
through this graph neural operator and
you have the embeddings okay and you do
it at every single scale you have this
information you collect them into an MLP
and you process. So the final formulas
for the encoder and this is where the
innovation in some sense comes in is
through here.
So you have this uh common feature
vector. So this WM is when you combine
both of them. So you have this uh graph
operator. This is the features geometric
embeddings they're thrown into an MLP
and this is what you get out of it. And
from different scales you accumulate
them through again a softmax some
attention weight. Right? So essentially
this you end up with what we call as
geometry aware tokens. So what is
sitting here at each point is let me use
a different color. What is sitting here
at each point is information that says
uh something about the features flow
field, pressure, temperature and so on.
Geometric information which says that
how far it is from the boundary, how
many points are there, what is the local
uh set of points and so on. Is it dense,
is it sparse, all this information is
conveyed and finally also some global
information about uh how how sort of
sharp or how smooth the field is and so
on. Some gradient information. So these
tokens or these objects are very very
rich in the source of information that
they have and they are sitting on a on a
reduced grid on a latent grid. So we can
process them and this is what I'll
describe next. But now at this point I
want to sort of ask you again the
details are not important anyway.
Shenang is going to explain this in the
next tutorial uh by explaining what are
the different uh elements of the code
that come into it. But in terms of the
basic idea, the structure is it clear
how this uh yeah go ahead.
>> So
there's no more message passing.
>> No, no more message passing because
message passing is expensive and we
don't do that. But the information is
conveyed through these kernels, right?
>> So there is still information coming in.
So you have uh xk is the point from
which information is pulled. Y is the
point where the information is being
pulled to. A is the feature that comes
from XK and this is passed into MLP. So
in a way you can say that we are anyway
accumulating information locally.
It's not technically message passing
because it isn't doesn't fit the
formulas that I wrote down before but it
is some form of information transfer
right. So you can think of it as message
passing but uh you you have no choice.
That's why it's called a graph neural
operator because you take information
there for the question. Yeah, go ahead.
>> But then don't you run into the same
issues of
memory.
>> I I'll I'll explain that because now the
issues are only restricted to the
encoder and the decoder and not to the
processor. Earlier all of it was sitting
inside uh and was destroying your
computer. So this is a very very good
question. The idea is to make as little
information
as as little compute as possible on the
encoder and decoder and to put all the
compute on the processor. So these are
very light layers in this huge uh I
think the biggest networks are in the
hundreds of millions. These are like I
don't know a few hundred thousand or
very light. That's the reason. Okay. But
I'll explain that. Yeah.
>> Yes. So um on the slide where you show
the grid with many space uh
>> is wait a little wait a little uh is
this one?
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know if it's randomly
>> but one of them doesn't have a point and
>> it's observed in vision transformers
that when you have empty tokens they can
be used either for like global context
>> or for like a scratch for calculator for
calculations. Did you observe or
>> similar similar behavior here? So
actually the void tokens also carry
information because they carry
information saying that hey there is no
flow here
>> or don't pay a lot of attention to that
point or something like that. So they're
not totally void.
>> So it's actually useful to have these
void tokens. Maybe if it's too many then
it's a waste of compute but uh it's it's
useful to have them. And the advantage
that this brings in we'll we'll come to
that slide in a sec. the advantage that
having this sort of cartian grid around
it is overwhelming. So it's worth having
this void tokens uh but it's very
similar observation.
>> Can you say that they carry some
information about the geometry?
>> They do carry information about the
geometry and they do carry information
about the flow. So they're not totally
void in in that sense. Right? So they're
uh maybe too many of them is not good.
But uh so but something you cannot you
can't have everything, right? You have
to you have to make some smart choices.
What is the processor now? So if you are
on a cartisian grid which is what our
recommendation is then you can just use
vision transformers because we know that
transformers are optimized and these
days you know transformers are really
optimized for all the kernels that are
used on in machine learning all the GPUs
and so on all the hardware. So this is a
big big advantage. So you can use
transformers vision transformers. So you
can do your uh uh patching and patch
embedding and so on. So if you are on
cartigian grades the advantage is that
you can do patching and you can use
visual transformers. So you can use
multiple blocks of them 10 12 15 blocks
and so on. But if you don't have this
cartigian structure if you are in the
second strategy then you have to use
your standard. The transformers can be
used anyway as long as you have a
sequence you can use a transformer. So
then you have to use your standard
transformer and it doesn't have the sort
of in. So then you have to take very few
points right here you can take as many
points as possible because you can
change the path size and you can work
here on the other hand you get better
representation of the geometry but the
sacrifice that you have to make is that
you have to take much fewer points. So
both of them are viable strategies. We
haven't pushed this strategy as much
because this strategy works very well.
But this also I know some people are
trying out this strategy now but uh this
is a viable strategy. Okay. So the idea
is to go as much of information on the
processor and this is what we do by
using transformers. Yeah.
>> Um
the thing about the patch approach is
that we increase uh resolution
our computer much but we have multiple
parts in this architecture. Would the
bottleneck then become something that
wasn't before? So like
>> no there is because you see that at the
end of the day the multiple the the
multiple scales
>> these uh okay this guys here when you
come to this stage their their role is
gone because they have all been
aggregated right so they have all been
aggregated and their role is gone. So
what you this is all in the encoder. So
all that the processor sees is uh a
single scale at which all the
information is there and then you
process that information. So the fact
that there are multiple scales in the
encoder does not interfere with the
processor. The processor is sort of drag
and drop. So we can use sw transformers
if you want to we can use something you
can use fn if you want to cno whatever.
So this is not uh interfering with the
others. it will increase if you have a
lot of scales it will increase the
compute on the encoder but not on the
processor.
>> Okay. So this is maybe Shashen will give
you some concrete numbers of how the so
actually the because we have a processor
which is so efficient even though the
processor is much much bigger its
compute is comparable to that of the
encoder and the decoder. So it's sort of
the numbers are just mindboggling in
that sense. Further questions? No. So
the processor is just a transformer. You
can use a transformer and then uh
information is aggregated and the
decoder as you can imagine it's just the
o opposite of the encoder right the
encoder goes this way
and the decoder anyway shang is going to
cover this in some detail so this is
going to go this way so now you have to
take information which is sitting on the
latent grid and you can have to come
back on the original point cloud
actually you don't need a point cloud we
have what is called a neural field
property so essentially any point any
query point you can come back.
So now let's say that you want to come
back to these blue points, right? Blue
points are the original points that you
wanted to evaluate the solution at
because you have some ground truth at
those points. So what you do is you
build the same structure again. So you
have information on the cartitionian
grids that is on the red points, right?
So then you look at all the in a
multiscale manner you look at all the
neighboring red points that contribute
to the blue point. You look at their
geometry, right? you look at the
geometry, you combine them into an MLP
and then you decode right through some
linear layer for instance and you come
back to this. The advantage is that any
query point can be served. So you don't
need any structure on it. Any query
point you just build the corresponding
uh neighborhoods, you accumulate the
information and do it. So this is why it
has what is called a neural field
property in the sense that what it
provides you you know with operator
learning the key is that the inputs are
functions and the outputs are functions
and this really respects that because it
provides you outputs at any point that
you wish for. So it has this nice neural
field property. So this is sort of more
or less the architecture in a nutshell
and as I said means uh Shang is going to
explain this in his tutorial to to some
extent. Actually this is didn't didn't
come out of nowhere. It is related to
what is called Geno which is what I
showed you after the break. So what go
does is that it has a GNO encoder and
decoder but this is single scale does
not have this attentional features and
so on and the main difference is that go
uses an FNO processor and FNO is as we
saw is not as accurate as transformers
right so are there any questions about
the architecture before we go to the
results and I have quite a few results
but uh no further questions okay good so
it's only when you sort of do it in code
that you learn about it but So the point
is that this is a very very flexible
architecture now right so any kind of
geome it's the same with the graphs
graphs are also very flexible so you can
do any kind of geometry here any kind of
domain geometry as you can see here this
is flow past supersonic flow past an air
foil right so supersonic flow past an
air foil as so there's a shock here
there are some transic shocks the
supersonic shocks trail shocks here so
this is a complex geometry this is a
flow same flow same flow conditions but
instead of having a air foil. It's a
ball here. So of course the the
structure is very very different but
it's able to resolve that. This is this
elasticity problem that I just told you.
It has this sort of graph structure. It
is again able to resolve that. So it's
very very flexible with respect to
geometry. But as I said this is nothing
surprising here because graphs can also
do the same thing. What is important
here and it's also very accurate because
remember
I did it very quickly yesterday. So very
I'll make these changes and then you can
get an updated version. It's very
accurate. So here is a bunch of
problems. Let's have a have a look at
them. So these air foil problems are
much harder than the ones that we saw
with the graph neuronet network. So what
do we compare it with? We compare it
with rigno which is our own own method
go and some other baselines which are
also quite interesting but I don't have
the time to describe them. So you can
see for instance let's to take two two
examples. Let's take this one pos signs
you know it's just uh on a circle right
and your forcing function is sin science
a sum of signs so exact solution is a
sum of science but these are very hard
because machine learning doesn't really
work in this you can see many of these
things fail completely on this problem
go is about 20% error is about 6% error
this gives you about 3% error similarly
this one is a flow past a bluff body
here for instance transolver does better
than code but overall you can see that
it has very it's a robust method it has
it does equally well on most problems
you can also do time dependent problems
for instance this one here is a
interesting one wave C science again you
have about 4% error similar to the graph
so it's it's not not very different so
again a lot of geometric flexibility as
well as accuracy right so that is the
that is the key that it is being
accurate Yes. Go ahead.
>> Um in previous lectures with CNO, we
also looked at air problems and
performance we find was good.
>> How would those perform on these?
>> We didn't try it. These are harder ones.
So, but the point is that there is no
chance of the geometry being resolved by
that, right? We use this masking
approach. Honestly, we didn't try to be
the these are as hard as maybe not the
hardest but these are pretty hard air
foil problems. So I would be very
surprised if uh in this setting that CNO
or any of the cartition methods will
work well because then they have to rely
entirely on masking. Maybe they will
work well in distribution and not
generalize well out of distribution. Um
I don't want to speculate it. It can be
done but the ones that come later they
cannot be done with the cartitionian
approach. You'll you'll see that very
quickly. But what about the efficiency?
Means the whole point was about
efficiency, right? And this is the
difference now. So let me try to explain
what goes on here. So let's focus on the
training throughput because bulk of time
inference is anyway quick, right?
Inference is uh seconds right or
subsecond.
Let's look at the training because
earlier this was my complaint that graph
neural network took 2 days to train on a
simple 2D problem. So how am I going to
do a 3D industrial scale problem? Right?
And the answer is you you cannot. So
let's look at two examples here. So this
is scaling or the throughput is the
number of samples that it can process
per second. So remember that data comes
in, right? The data comes in uh you
churn through the data in in a gradient
descent step go to the next batch of
data, next batch of data, next batch of
data, a fixed amount of compute, fixed
number of samples, fixed number of
epochs and you sort of run through that.
So the training throughput tells you how
many samples you can process per uh
second essentially. So now let us look
at things that we already know. Let's
look at uh rigno right because we have
already seen it. So as you can see this
is with the input size means the size of
the input to the problem right and we go
all the way from and now I can't see but
a,000 points uh to 10,000 points to
100,000 points right and then later on
we'll go towards a million points but uh
you'll see so let us look at a 10,000
points so at for,000 points this is
quite quite effective this is something
like a,000 uh samples per second can be
evaluated right but when you go to
something like I don't know 40,000 or 20
30 40 50,000 points you can see that
these methods they really drop down they
so for instance transolver this can only
do about 10 samples per second okay so
if your data set has 8,000 samples you
can do 10 samples per second you need
800 seconds per epoch right uh and if
you need 800 seconds per epoch and you
need let's say 1,000 epochs then this is
800 seconds is already how many minutes
is that? 12 minutes is it or 13 minutes
roughly per epoch. And if you have a,000
epochs, this is a lot of time. So in an
hour you can do something like five
epochs, right? And then to do a,000
epochs it's 200 hours which is 10 days.
So this is impractical right and this is
the reason and if you go and this falls
right it it falls quite a bit. It is in
this regime that both go and goat
they're able to handle it. So for
instance, go is still able to do
something like 80 samples per second. So
something like 10 12 times 10 times more
and order of magnitude more which is
what what we really need, right? And
similarly with the size of the model. So
this was of a fixed model size when the
model size increases. So this is number
of parameters. Let's look at something
like 80 million parameters, right?
Because you need a big model to be able
to process a lot of data. So then you
can see that again uh ignore the graph
new network. It just fails because it is
only sampling three or four samples per
second whereas here you are yeah you are
like quite quite a bit right 60 70
samples per second so you are you have
the training throughput it's not very
different from go they are comparable to
each other go and zeno to some extent
but the what differs is accuracy because
go simply doesn't have the accuracy it
has the efficiency but not the accuracy
and this is based on quite a few
implementation tricks Um again maybe Sen
will tell you how the information is
moved between or how the compute is
distributed between encoder and the
processor and how more of the compute is
put on the processor and not on the
encoder and the decoder. So there are
there are some smart tricks but in a in
a in a lecture it's pointless to explain
these tricks. Now this is what explains
the radar chart that I wanted to show
you. So remember that on this axis is
efficiency on this axis is accuracy. So
goat is a very accurate method as you
can see but it's no I wouldn't say it's
significantly more accurate than than
rigno particularly for time dependent
problems they are sort of similar to
each other time independent problems it
seems to do a better job uh
significantly better job but it is in
efficiency that it really scores because
genome for instance is also efficient
it's some sitting somewhere here uh
quite efficient but it is not accurate
right because these guys are stopping
somewhere here so when you combine the
two is the trick and this is where the
combination of this graph neural
networks light encoders coupled with
this heavy transformer processor and all
these multiscale aggregation and so on
this increase efficiency and increase
accuracy while not sacrificing
efficiency so it's able to combine the
best of both worlds and once it is able
to combine the best of both worlds what
we can do because of its scalability is
that we can really go to 3D because so
far in the course I have not shown you a
single 3D data set right and this But
now from the next from this lecture
onwards it's mostly about 3D data sets.
We have to go more towards the real
world and uh this is what I'm going to
explain. Are there any questions so far?
No. Anyways you see in the tutorial what
happens. So let me give you three
examples of 3D data sets and then we can
can finish a bit early even. So this is
what is called driver++. It's one of the
data sets that is out there. It's
actually very it's released by people at
MIT Fmed and his group. So what they
have is they have taken 8,000 car shapes
okay
passenger cars not race cars but
passenger cars and then they have run
open foam which is uh
industrial not industrial but common CFD
software for different kinds of shapes.
These are you can see coupes,
hatchbacks, notchbacks and so on. And
they used what is called RANs. Okay. So
RANS is Rol's average Navia Stokes
equation which is the standard in
industrial CFD means this is what people
use. It's not the most accurate one. So
you don't need a lot of uh and if you
just want to concentrate on the surface
because people are interested in the
surface body forces, it's about half a
million nodes. So remember 8,000 car
shapes and half a million nodes. If I
would have used rigno, it wouldn't work.
Right? This is precisely the regime
where I told you that it fails very very
badly. So then go of course and go also
can work. No problems with that. So at
least in the public domain
for quite a while this was the most at
least the most accurate data set. So you
you just give the input mesh of the car.
So you give the shape of the car and you
give the flow conditions and it is going
to output for instance the pressure on
the surface when the car goes with at
certain speed. the and the sheer stress
the stress that the air puts on the car
and these are done fairly accurately I
would say uh in this in this particular
case and uh yeah at at the time of
writing it it still I think is the most
at least publicly there are some
companies private companies startups
which claim to have beaten this but they
don't give you any information how they
did it right so publicly it is still the
most accurate method particularly on the
wall she stress it it provid provides
quite a bit of uh uh improvement over
the over what what was there before and
the main advantage here is the speed of
course once you have trained it it
doesn't take long to train this training
took less than a day on this 3D
industrial scale data set right but for
a single simulation these people at MIT
they use 375 node hours of compute
that's quite quite a lot and the
inference time is 1/3 of a second right
because this is the advantage once
you've trained it you can really do
industrial you scale things at at no no
no cost essentially right so this is the
result on this on this particular data
set but you can scale it even more so
there is another benchmark this changes
um from a rans to what is called lees a
highly resolved uh large simulation this
was a data set that's released by Neil
Ashton who is now at Nvidia but he was
at Amazon at that time when he generated
it's approximately 500 cars it's much
much more expensive Ive you know now a
single car is about 61,000 node hours to
compute earlier it was 300 right so this
is like one order of magnitude a factor
of 20 more compute it's a lot lot of
money that he used to generate this data
set uh yeah and then uh it's more
accurate right because it replaces the
simulation by something which is more
accurate and in general it has like 9
million surface nodes 10 million so it's
20 times more the comput is also 20s
times more but the resolution is also 20
times more. There are some uh other
again some companies which have uh used
information but this is not so much a
publicly at least on the full mesh we
didn't find a lot of information and
again goat does quite well it does
better than go for sure and uh yeah so
you can run this and you can do it with
some high level of accuracy so you can
do this kind of industrial problems
simply because now it takes about 10 to
14 seconds to run because you also have
to build the graph it's a lot of mesh
points, right? So, at inference, it's
about 10 seconds, but compared to 61,000
hours, if I'm even relatively accurate,
this gives you a lot of freedom that uh
that that's not there before. And the
last one that I wanted to show you today
was uh an aircraft data set. Uh it's
from um DLR, the German Aerospace
Agency, Philip Echimayer. And what he
and his co-workers did is that they took
something called a community research
model. Now the actual aircraft shape is
uh run by companies Airbus, Boeing and
so on and they don't give you the data
means I I I know people at these
companies and you know the NDAs are like
uh the the agreements I'm not kidding
because I'm in the middle of signing one
it's the length of this table you have
to read that much of fine print in order
to get some data because they don't this
is uh industrial information right but
uh this is a sort of a community
research model so there is more
information that is available out there
and again uh the number of it's again
rans so it's not as many nodes it's
about a million nodes and then you can
very accurately compute the the wall
shear stress you can very accurately
compute the body forces but with with
goat compared to go for instance but go
also does relatively well on these
problems okay so this is what all that I
wanted to say so the main difference be
from the lectures before is now we reach
a level where the technology is advanced
enough that we can really go to the real
world data sets Right? Before that it
was all cartisian grids but all that
information was not wasted because we
learned about transformers, we learned
about convolutions, we learned about
different kinds of aggregation
methodologies, craft neural networks but
we are able to combine them and slowly
in the last one year I would say that
the community or even one year I would
say 6 months the community has moved to
a point where we can really use machine
learning for industrial scale
simulations. These were not possible
even even the last uh course when I
taught one year ago I didn't have this
material because this has really changed
in the last year and not just from my
lab but from other places also. So this
is a very dynamic uh space. Okay. So we
are a bit ahead of time and uh that's
good because I didn't take a long enough
break. So what we do in the next lecture
is that we up the ante even more and try
to go to even harder problems uh where
we need generative AI. this
discriminative AI is not going to be
good enough. So the next lecture will be
about diffusion models and the last
lecture that I give will be on
foundation models. So I have two two
more lectures left and then David is
going to talk about chemistry and
biology where he will focus more on
graph neuronet networks because graph
neuronet networks for molecules
molecules there this will be insane that
a molecule will have 10 million nodes
right this is uh then you don't have a
molecule anymore you have something else
but you don't need that uh but there
graph neural networks are still the king
they do well there okay so see you in
the next lecture next uh uh Thursday